the only con I would say that comes with
traveling for work is that it is much
harder to gain a healthy work-life
balance it can be hard to get into a
routine for example meal prepping is
pretty impossible to do if your schedule
is constantly changing or even if you're
a consultant who travels from Monday to
Thursday then you're only home for a few
days out of the week so you tend to do
things like going out to eat instead of
prepping your meals I just want to
stress and underline this because here
again I completely agree and the problem
is that in most cases Monday morning you
will need to wake up really early to get
one of the earlier flights so depending
a bit of your location the connection
often you will need to wake up at 5am
sometimes even earlier so this means you
already start your work week with some
kind of sleep deficit and then this just
continues building over the work week
and then usually on Thursday evening or
then when the week is over you really
need to do lots of sleeping on the
weekend to recover